the character of Ernest Burkhart I found
absolutely
fascinating Ernest comes to Oklahoma and
ultimately falls in love with Molly
kylei I don't know what she said but
must have been Indian for handsome
devil William K halil used that as an
opportunity to pray upon her wealth oh
say they're going to go they time is
over erus is under a very strong
influence of his uncle he finds himself
getting deeper into murderous land I'm
sorry for all
troubles working with Leo and watching
this master create this
character it's
unbelievable Ernest a real life
representation of the incredible greed
of that time I just love
money I love it as much as I love my
[Music]
wife